olá boa tarde
é muito bom estar aqui com vocês eu vim
falar um pouquinho sobre o projeto ttt
brasileiros
nós somos um grupo de voluntários que
dedicam um pouco de seu tempo para
divulgar as idéias que merecem ser
divulgadas em vários idiomas
o projeto começou em 2009 com apenas 300
traduções em 40 idiomas
ele nasceu da vontade de alguns
tradutores em fazer com que essas idéias
pudessem ser acessadas por suas
comunidades
essas idéias que lhe se inspiravam tanto
em 2012
o projeto começou a incluir as palestras
tex e também pede é atualmente com uma
nova marca até trailers são mais de 100
idiomas que são feitas as traduções
contamos com a colaboração de mais de 25
mil voluntários em 155 países mês
passado atingimos a marca de mais de
100.000 traduções publicadas
se você se perguntou no começo desse
evento quem estava por trás daquelas
legendas hoje todas as que vocês vêem no
dia a dia
gostaria de mostrar alguma dessas
pessoas este foi uma um encontro de
produtores no estado de são paulo em
são mais de 900 pessoas ajudando a
espalhar idéias em português brasileiro
com mais de 4500 traduções publicadas
somos a segunda maior comunidade de
tradução em número de traduções
é crucial que a gente entenda o trabalho
do tradutor para essas excelentes que
não são dados em inglês nos eventos
soldado originalmente em outras línguas
assim a gente consegue ver ele espalhar
essas idéias para outras comunidades
a gente consegue entender o trabalho do
tradutor como crucial para espalhar
essas idéias em outros países para
pessoas de outras comunidades e até para
poder publicar as palestras deste evento
no site oficial do ted
se você quer se juntar a nós para ajudar
um pouco a divulgar essas idéias em
português brasileiro
acesse o site do ted no menu superior
direito
clique em participei e translate
na página que vai abrir a seguir basta
clicar em vitória e aplainar aqui neste
evento
a gente tem que entender também que nem
todo mundo fala outros idiomas se você
não se sente confortável em traduzir uma
palestra
você pode ajudar nós a transcrever para
isso basta saber falar português
a gente consegue com essas tratos essas
transcrições espalhar para que ela seja
traduzida para mais pessoas no mundo
inteiro
além disso nos dá a possibilidade de
primitivo que pessoas que tenham alguma
dificuldade de o ver também de acessar
essas ideias que merecem ser espalhadas
eu fico muito feliz de poder divulgar
isso porque pra vocês hoje e eu vou
estar disponível caso tenha qualquer
dúvida
obrigado
[Aplausos]